I'm black I'm black I'm black I'm black
I'm black I'm black I'm white
[Music]
okay for sure now uh one quick question
I gotta ask are there any other like
Africans or anybody with like any like
Afrocentric ethnicities my dad has
Nigerian in him uh what tribe do you
know what tribe actually I don't but my
mom's Ashkenazi Russian Jew and then my
dad's literally like he got Nigerian all
the way from Asian to he's literally
mixed with everything okay for sure for
sure
anyone else
nope just black yeah I got nicknames
well and Rosebud is actually my stream
my my street name my real name's Riley
my name is Fitzgerald that's like the
full first name but then fist is like
the nickname people call me by Lady
Fitzy yeah sometimes they do 50
sometimes they be doing Fitzy I think my
strategy was to kind of just just be
black I'm not gonna lie when you said
Fitz I thought it was because you had
tough fits on you know
I can't even see him what you talking
about
I mean if you could see you'd probably
be able to tell that I got a tough fit
on you I wasn't even funny can we all
say what we wearing and everything I got
a skeleton all red varsity jacket cargo
pants on the side what's up we matching
right now I'm not wearing the skeleton
fit but I got like red you got Air
Forces on I got Air Forces
I wish I could dab you up right now but
wait what type force is yak I don't know
so I got the Air Force Ones with like
the little black stripe on it okay yeah
half half black half white oh I see
where you're going to have blackheads No
Cap I used to wear some boom is that
we're a half black and half white
because of that my whole life my
strategy for today was to figure out
who's safe rather than figure out who's
the mole right off the bat who's one of
the brothers you feel me who here knows
what the smell of a hot comb on a hedge
this thing this thing real bad what are
some prominent songs that you're gonna
hear at a family reunion oh they played
a lot of Blues Marvin seeds Bobby Blue
Bland then when I got drunker it was
Tupac
his vocal inflections like it just it
kind of it made me think of you know
Straight Out of Compton the movie maybe
it felt too black you know for a second
yeah I grew up on classic rock from my
mom's side and then I grew up on Motown
for my dad's side so anytime you know
summer vacation in the backyard my nana
she'd be playing almost Town my pop-up
and then I'll be dancing slow dancing to
it you know
[Music]
thank you
everyone has one person that's
suspicious of them so we know we're
basically
so I'm gonna start off with a theme song
you finish it we're brothers
we're happy and we're sitting here
okay okay
Me growing up half black half white
there's certain songs that they sing
that I honestly didn't know word by word
what to what to say in the movie ATL
Rashad was running his daddy's house
into what age
oh
it's a famous line y'all we got another
I ain't gonna cover I don't even know
the answer to that one
complete this song uh that boy got
stretch pants foreign
I got one I got one anybody know what it
is when you say you put your foot in
something um
I was listening so intently on on voices
because you ever been on the phone with
like telemarketer you can tell us a
black person on the other side so you
throw out little hints you know while
you're talking I'm like oh yeah we cool
I was trying to catch that calling
response won't he do it yes he will who
who said that Brevin Jay I'm suspicious
everybody else over here
now all black people don't go to church
now but they notice this is true what
flavor of Kool-Aid was your favorite
growing up red red I like grape you mean
purple
yeah that's kind of suspicious
where I'm from we go by colors we don't
go by we don't go by that which you just
said wait wait hold on why is that it's
crazy because grape and purple exactly
the same thing I mean we used to call it
we used to call Welch's grape soda I
don't know it's just where I'm from we
go by colors we go by colors grape
Kool-Aid not purple red flag he was
trying to come at me about the grape but
honestly that I grew up with a bunch of
friends and we all called it that in
Harlem how you make your Kool-Aid you
pour the sugar to the ancestor say stop
laughs
in the Summers it was either with you
outside or inside you had to pick right
like yeah one no running up and inside
your house you know so y'all y'all feel
that yeah yeah you don't let that good
air out when it comes to black women
from the 90s who do you think of offer
it be along I'm gonna say Holly Berry
damn I'm gonna say uh uh uh uh
she was a rapper um
wow what's her name Rhapsody Jada
Pinkett or the sister from wait you
can't take two dog you taking forever
goodness somebody gotta help me out with
this shoddy from like black panther
who's the queen you feel me yeah I know
her name but you gotta know Angela all
right here we go there we go I think uh
a Whitley from a different world I can't
remember her name the old girl from A
Different World growing up watching my
sister's Raven Simone Tyra Banks from
that runway show
um is that 90s Tyra's from the 90s I was
sitting back watching them being like
sheesh
foreign
[Music]
when it comes to being black man
microaggressions let's talk about it I
got you right here man I went to a pwi
man I'd be chilling in the corner
there's only five percent of us but
somehow they found a way to take a
picture of you
yeah for the diversity right I'm like
they only five percent I Gotta Give Them
credit though because like finding us
it's gonna be a little bit tough but
like they found a way regardless I ain't
never gonna lie Loke I'm I'm real lost
we from the streets I ain't even get
that far like college enough like that
hey we all got a different Journey
that's cool yeah it's like the low-key
racist thing yeah I'm not like you're so
well spoken wow why wouldn't I be I'm a
grown man black guy you're so well
spoken yeah you peep game you walk down
the street right and a white folks see
you the first thing they do when they
see you or acknowledge you they fold
their lips like and knock their head
down make that weird little space on the
sidewalk or even step in the street yeah
or clutch
take the next elevator yes all of that
all of that hello room in the elevator
too like you ain't supposed to be here
what was one of y'all favorite movies
growing up you feel me like loving
basketball don't be a menace I mean what
did y'all watch I like New Jack City
that was all right you from New York
yeah so you already know like I am My
Brother's Keeper and that's some real
[__] so I'll tell you what man I watched
the uh the first Power Rangers movie
like twice a day for like the first four
years after it came out man Power
Rangers yeah Power Rangers what season
what season oh Mighty Morphin Mighty
Morphin facts is hard it is I watch I
watch anime too oh wait are you watch
anime
y'all Naruto come on like don't laugh at
me but I love the Disney Channel
Originals you know what I'm saying oh no
no that was good
let's watch the Disney boys y'all know
about that static shock though come on I
was literally just about to say
superheroes static shots I met his voice
actor bro you did film my dude is called
dope bro he voices every single black
every single black everything and
Samurai Jack he said he's got range bro
he's got range all right I got a
question because I feel like we just
gonna be be like we gonna be vibing Man
Too Much yeah even if you wait we gotta
tap in for real hey yeah okay why does
that bother you yeah
you have to point that out bro okay so
in regards to dating and whatnot my
first girlfriend she ended up being a
Russian girl and my dad was he he always
should throw hints like hey man
you know she's nice and all that stuff
and like he wouldn't he would never say
it but I knew like the upbringing he had
he dealt with a lot of racism stuff so
he kind of had like the hesitance for
like those type of relationships did
your parents or you know family members
like say hey like I mean my mother was
from Shreveport so you know she used to
be on that uh and she was older when she
had me she was already like in her late
50s so okay she wasn't playing with none
of that really I don't think my parents
ever put they just want me to love who I
love but at the same time I think
there's always that underlying like you
know we would love for it to be a black
woman you know what I mean yeah it was
actually the same for me they never said
don't bring a white girl home or
anything like that but I definitely know
how it will make them feel if I was to
bring home a sister for sure like oh
sure like you're with somebody who
understands you right who can understand
what you go through in life as a black
man on the day to day-to-day basis from
the microaggressions to the ridiculous
racism in your face my people were cool
whatever like I'm cool whatever too but
like I appreciate the sister like
because she understands me and I don't
have to explain myself
[Music]
we have a tie between Rob
and Brevin
yeah I'll hit that side or leave
okay I'm Brevin I'm from Louisville
Kentucky like I said I didn't have a
traditional like upbringing as far as
like dating a lot of different people
because I'm a queer black man but it
took me a long time to get there but as
far as home life I had two parents uh
two older brothers a little sister super
close yeah
um this is hard I don't know I'm black
y'all I'm black my name Robert I'll go
by Rob I'm from South Central L.A we
bounced all around it was just me and my
mother three sisters and two brothers
I've been in and out the streets not too
much school and that's pretty much it
foreign
[Music]
it seemed like he was privileged and I
relate more to struggle hearing some of
the things he was saying it kind of like
made me think in my second guess
in my brain I was like this is probably
just like one of those cases where you
could be white and he's just a product
of his environment Brevin you can't vote
I appreciate the try bro it looks like
we are tied again wow what I voted to
Rob just because I think I heard
everyone else speak a little bit more I
also voted Rob first of all you know I
I'm just gonna say that like the
environment he grew up with now I'm
saying I think that like you know that's
just a case where he could like relate
to a lot of like black people's
struggles you feel me but he might not
be like black in and of himself I voted
for Brevin to get out
um not because anything bad but it was
more so because of when Rob was talking
I felt like I was listening to one of my
cousins talk
um
and he definitely sounds like he's from
South Central for sure not a whole lot
of white people down there
so
I'ma say he stays Rob black that's it
yeah I know that's the fact Rob black
you sound like people from my way so he
said no offense to you Brandon but but
you got kick rocks
I heard them both for sure but Rob like
I feel like I could say certain things
to Rob and pick up on it quick if I say
something certain things to the others
like is you gonna really relate or yeah
you know no disrespect what does hit and
lick
foreign
[Music]
take me away
yeah Rob sound like he no good catfish
I'm not sure why I got voted out I feel
that a lot of times I've felt that I'm
too white for the black people and too
black for the white people but it's okay
it's all good I think the mole is still
in the box and you want to continue
playing the game raise your hand
no stop what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing I knew I wasn't
gonna get eliminated
um why is that
I don't know I just came in like I was
gonna win really already said I was
gonna win so anybody else got a question
all right so let's make things a little
bit spicy you feel me what's like one
critique and or what's one thing that
you think like black people could be
like doing better or like a hot take
about like black people in you know our
community and stuff like that since the
beginning of the US
um with the obvious mistreatment of
black people a lot of information
pertaining to being able to further us
as a people has been withheld from us
and more star recently the information
has been normalized to be pushed out in
this generation is really doing a lot to
make sure that we are as gamed up as
possible with all the tax information
with all that stuff so we can no longer
have those continuing circumstances of
not having the information to be able to
financially evolve as a people and I
think that's dope but I also think that
people need to really be on that p's and
q's with that stuff because the more we
sit around and don't go out this
information the more our situation
continues to remain the same financially
even though we spend some of the most
money in the US it never stays within
the black community the gangbanger
that got a spot elaborate on that well
it's no point of gang banger no more I
mean
uh if you think about it you gangbanger
uh and then it got so bad where you know
everybody that run black in prison is
together even if you from the enemy side
upside or anything so if you go to
prison so if I if I supposed to gang
bang shoot somebody and if I get caught
it and I gotta go to prison and get
along with the people who I just slid on
it don't make no sense and there's no
money involved
feel that so it's just it's that's
that's the first thing gotta go don't be
so quick to buy Gucci pride and Louie
like I mean I'm not wanting to speak
myself I got Ricks and subion but at the
same time like if one of the homies has
a brand you should be going to go buy
that you know I feel like uh a critique
is just my little brother is uh he's at
a HBCU a small one in Oklahoma and uh
nothing against like the school or
anything of people is around but I feel
like the ideas and uh and like the
mindsets that he's been around from his
uh you know early childhood and whatnot
because uh have been just like not
open-minded to new possibilities
opportunities are out there we just got
you know open-minded to it and try to
figure out what works for us you know
this might be on the fault of like the
media but I think sometimes we over
sensationalize like our pain and I think
that there's so much more to like the
black community whether it's Joy or like
having a good laugh or something like
there's just so much more to us and like
you know the pain that we go through and
I think that needs to be you know shown
more in like our movies our TV shows
just like the way we talk about like the
way we talk about things like I think
there's just so much more to the black
community than that I want to see black
people doing goofy stuff on screen not
just being slaves you know right come on
now talk about it or criminals or or
other gangsters that's not even like a
thing for America but like you go to
China you go to like some of these other
places like that's all they see of us
word y'all would be real I think we're
all good bro
foreign
[Music]
sorry Gabriel you know I'm saying it
happens
if you think the mole is still in the
box and you like to continue the game
raise your hand
all right so that's unanimous we're
going to end the game right then and
there okay if the lights turn green
that means you voted the mole out and
you all win if the lights turn red that
means the mole is still in the box
and you all lose the fat popped in my
head of what if you had it wrong the
whole time and the guy right next to you
is the one three
two
one
it is red that means the mole is still
here
you guys can lift your blindfolds in
three
[Laughter]
two
one
[Music]
that's a problem
of course there's been like a couple
white boys who cool but like not like
Rob like that was different my name is
Robert but uh they call me milk I'm from
South Central I got adopted at seven
days old as a baby like out the hospital
to a black mother so I was raised with
her ever since seven days old that's
crazy my whole family is black I didn't
even know the other I never met other
people until I was like that's dope
grown wrong my upbringing was a little
strange I was the only white kid at
every party every birthday but I never
really I never really like bothered me I
guess is it hard for you to fit in with
white people
oh it was it's getting a little better
what about for black people then is it
easier or is it more difficult to get
along no no no no I mean I saw I was
around my whole life jail county jail
juvenile hall every party everything and
your whole family like they just all
accept you because I got signs of my
white family that like they wouldn't
even hold me as a baby because I had a
black death not hell no no I had a good
family since my mom married a black man
they sat shibbets for her which
basically in the Jewish community means
that you're dead to me and it's almost
um
lone feeling that you get sometimes when
you feel like you can't relate to
anybody I was like the baby Loki like
the youngest one wow
[Applause]
what is a misconception people have
about black men put us in a box that
basically states that we're always angry
or mad there's a lot of happy Black Folk
in the world like me personally I'm
happy we're not as monolithic as a lot
of people would make us out to be we are
Bankers we're lawyers we're doctors we
all originated from Africa we all
because you're further away from the
equator it doesn't matter black is
beautiful